ein schritt nach links saskia esken und
norbert walter borjans sind die neuen
spd-vorsitzenden das führungsduo will
die partei neu ausrichten
ein ort der sprachlos macht bei ihrem
ersten besuch in auschwitz warnt die
bundeskanzlerin das in deutschland hass
antisemitismus und gewalt zu nehmen und
eine epidemie die vermeidbar wäre
weltweit sind wieder millionen menschen
durch masern in lebensgefahr
die uno schlägt alarm
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers ende der woche einen
nachrichten freitag schön dass sie dabei
sind
guten abend auch ann christin die
nachher den sport im blick genau wie
handball und fußball guten habt die spd
und damit beginnen wir heute hat zwei
neue parteichefs saskia esken und
norbert walter borjans sind vom
parteitag in berlin gewählt worden
es ist das erste gemischte führungsteam
in der geschichte der sozialdemokratie
die beiden kündigten einen neuen
linkskurs der partei an und der
parteitag hat heute abend auch erstmal
für neue verhandlungen mit der union
gestimmt
details aus berlin von andreas huppert
und lars bohnsack die erleichterung ist
groß 89 prozent für norbert walter
borjans 76 für saskia esken
das ist mehr als der zustand der partei
erwarten ließ mit ihrem führungsduo will
die spd in eine neue zeit gehen soll
heißen mit einem klareren und vor allem
linkeren profil wenn es links ist dass
wir das auseinanderdriften unserer
gesellschaft nicht akzeptieren wollen
dann haben wir nichts gegen diese
einordnung wenn es links ist dass die
rente mit steuer mit beträgen oder
beiträgen aus der groß vermögenden stück
gestärkt wird damit alle wirklich in
würde alt sein können
dann sind wir links alles soll auf den
prüfstand auch die politik der eigenen
minister wenn die schwarze null einer
besseren zukunft für unsere kinder
entgegen steht dann ist sie falsch
dann muss sie weg allerdings einen
sofortigen ausstieg aus der gruppe
fordern die neun ausdrücklich nicht ein
freifahrschein wollen sie dem
regierungsbündnis mit der union aber
auch nicht ausstellen
ich war und ich bin skeptisch was die
zukunft dieser großen koalition angeht
habe ich meine meinung nicht geändert
aber mit diesem leitantrag geben wir der
koalition eine realistische chance auf
eine fortsetzung nicht mehr aber auch
nicht weniger
die parteibasis hofft jetzt dass mit der
neuen führung endlich wieder ruhe in die
spd einkehrt was die spd gar keine
andere wahl hat als sich aufzumachen in
eine neue zeit und ich habe schon die
hoffnung
dass wir das mit den neuen vorsitzenden
schaffen können das sind die beiden
jetzt vorangehen gemeinsam müssen wir
aber aus der krise gehen ich glaube es
ist ganz wichtig dass wir die
innerparteiliche solidarität wieder
stärken und deutlich machen wofür wir
stehen antrag eine mehrheit der spd
steht jedenfalls weiter zur großen
koalition einem antrag der groko gegner
sofort aus der regierung auszusteigen
wurde am abend eine deutliche absage
erteilt und die einschätzung jetzt noch
live aus berlin von matthias fornoff
matthias guten abend ja war das heute
ein neuer anfang für eine partei die so
etwas wie einen erfrischenden neuanfang
ja dringend sucht
zumindest ist es mal das ende einer
monatelangen quälenden suche nach dem
neuen führungsduo da ist erleichterung
spürbar nach einem gebrauchten jahr für
die spd
egal wie erfrischend der neuanfang mit
aspen und walter borjans denn ist oder
empfunden wird
die neuen parteichefs haben hier
klassische sozialdemokratische
gerechtigkeits themen betont und ein
paar linke akzente gesetzt
das gros aus am nikolaus das haben sie
bei aller skepsis nicht gefordert und
was heißt der tag ist für die zukunft in
der großen koalition wie geht es da
weiter
da die spd sendet im grunde gemischte
signale in richtung union
es ist ein ja aber zur großen koalition
die partei will weiter gestalten
nachverhandeln ihre ziele durchsetzen
etwa einen deutlich höheren mindestlohn
wenn das aber nicht funktioniert ist die
sinnfrage schnell wieder auf dem tisch
denn die fliehkräfte die raus wollen aus
der ungeliebten koalition
die sind immer noch stark falls es zu
neuwahlen kommen sollte ist das risiko
eines politischen debakel für die spd
groß und das schweißt zusammen die
partei und auch die gruppe
matthias vielen dank und dieser hinweis
noch für sie dem parteitag der spd den
können sie im live stream auf heute de
verfolgen
und dort gibt es auch die reden der
beiden neuen parteichefs noch mal in
voller länge unser nächstes thema die
deutsche wirtschaft hat ein rasant
wachsendes problem cyberkriminalität
immer mehr angriffe auf wichtige
computernetzwerke in immer kürzeren
abständen
jetzt hat es bmw getroffen und zwar
offenbar massiv insgesamt kann der
schaden für die deutschen firmen nur
geschätzt werden mehr als 100 milliarden
euro pro jahr
dabei kommen die meisten angriffe aus
deutschland selbst gefolgt von osteuropa
und asien
im konkreten fall bei bmw geht es weder
um sabotage noch um erpressung sondern
wohl um klassische industriespionage und
die spur führt nach vietnam
alexander pohl für experten ist klar bmw
wurde nicht zufällig ausgewählt sofort
der münchner autobauer an mehreren
zukunftstechnologien gleichzeitig wie
etwa der brennstoffzelle ein lohnendes
ziel
bw ist ein technologie offenes
unternehmen führend in gleich mehreren
antriebstechnologien alle unternehmen in
deutschland die technologieführer sind
somit auch diese außer
automobilindustrie sind potentielle
ziele
getarnt als thailändischer
bmw-niederlassung verschafften sich die
hacker zugang zum netzwerk des
autoherstellers monatelang wurden bmw
rechner nach nützlichen ordnern und
dateien durchsucht das ergab eine
recherche des bayerischen rundfunks das
unternehmen äußerte sich heute nur
schriftlich wir haben strukturen und
prozesse implementiert die das risiko
von unerlaubten externen zugriffen auf
unsere systeme minimieren und uns im
ereignisfall eine schnelle entdeckung
aufklärung und wiederherstellung
ermöglichen
die hacker gruppe die sich ocean lotus
nennt stammt aus vietnam
sie steht im verdacht für den
vietnamesischen staat zu spionieren
möglich auch dass sie für einen anderen
geber gearbeitet hat vietnam lediglich
eine geeignete operationsbasis war
dort gibt es eine ganz andere
sicherheitsarchitektur als
beispielsweise in deutschland in
deutschland würden solche angriffe sehr
sehr gut verfolgt werden dies liegt in
vietnam nicht vor
der cyber angriff auf bmw war wohl nicht
der letzte auf deutsche hersteller die
seien sich der risiken bewusst sagen
fachleute
bei den gegenmaßnahmen jedoch gebe es
noch handlungsbedarf
antisemitismus rassismus eine welle von
hass delikten das erleben wir zunehmend
in deutschland mahnt die bundeskanzlerin
heute und zwar an einem ort an dem diese
realität noch viel schwerer wiegt dass
frühere ns vernichtungslager auschwitz
hier quälen die nationalsozialisten mehr
als eine million menschen so lange bis
sie sterben oder ermordeten sie sofort
die zahl so groß dass grauen so schwer
vorstellbar wer je in der heutigen
gedenkstätte in auschwitz birkenau war
wird das was er dort sieht niemals mehr
vergessen angela merkel ist die erste
bundeskanzlerin an diesem ort seit 24
jahren
von dort berichtet natalie steger angela
merkel will ein zeichen setzen gegen
antisemitismus und gegen jede form der
diskriminierung bei ihrer ersten reise
nach auschwitz eine schweige lehnt an
der sogenannten todes wand erschossen
die nazis tausende von menschen die
kanzlerin trifft auch überlebende
sie berichten über das grauen die capos
lachten und sagten ihr wollt in die
freiheit seht ihr diese kamine der
einzige weg von hier in die freiheit
führt durch diese kamine auschwitz ihr
haben die deutschen gequält und
grauenhaft getötet die meisten opfer
waren juden
auschwitz steht weltweit für eine
maschinerie des morgens die kanzlerin
wendet sich gegen jeden versuch diese
verbrechen von damals heute zu
relativieren
in diesen tagen ist es nötig das
deutlich zu sagen denn wir erleben einen
besorgniserregenden rassismus eine
zunehmende intoleranz eine welle von
hass delikten
wir erleben einen angriff auf die
grundwerte der liberalen demokratie und
einen gefährlichen
geschichtsrevisionismus angela merkel
ist auf einladung der stiftung
auschwitz-birkenau gekommen
deutschland wird die stiftung mit
weiteren 60 millionen euro unterstützen
für den erhalt der gedenkstätte auf dem
ehemaligen kz-gelände die konservierung
der backstein baracken etwa zeugnisse
des holocausts ist eine endlose aufgabe
es geht um den kampf gegen das vergessen
denn die zeit zeugen werden weniger
unser nächstes thema wie werden abi
noten in deutschland vergleichbar war
wie kann der schulwechsel in ein anderes
bundesland erleichtert werden
diese fragen sollte eigentlich ein
nationaler bildungsrat beantworten das
vorhaben ist aber gescheitert am
widerstand aus bayern und aus baden
württemberg die fürchteten der bund
bekomme zu großen einfluss
die länder haben jetzt stattdessen auf
ihrer kultusministerkonferenz
beschlossen im kommenden jahr einen
eigenen bildungsrat zu gründen ohne den
bund mehr von carsten behrendt sie
stehen in berlin kurz vor dem abi und
sind genervt vom flickenteppich im
deutschen schulwesen der schlechten
vergleichbarkeit unter den bundesländern
wenn ich jetzt sagen möchte ich möchte
euch einander lmu in münchen zum
beispiel studieren ich habe einfach
nicht die gleichen voraussetzungen wie
leute die in bayern ihr abitur machen
die länder wollen ihre systeme
harmonisieren abschlussnoten besser
vergleichbar machen allerdings ohne
nationalen bildungsrat ohne den bund in
berlin beschloss die
kultusministerkonferenz einstimmig einen
expertenrat allein auf länder ebene die
ziele in allen hauptfächern einheitliche
standards eine gemeinsame abituraufgaben
sammlung aber kein deutschlandweites 10
abitur jetzt kommen wir zu einem klaren
schnitt zu einer klaren
zuständigkeitsverteilung länder haben
die zuständigkeit für die schule
sie müssen sich in der
kultusministerkonferenz zusammenfinden
sie werden dieses gremium einrichten sie
tragen dann natürlich auch die
politische verantwortung für das was da
rauskommt
die botschaft schuld politik bleibt
ländersache
das aus für den nationalen bildungsrat
hält die lehrergewerkschaft für den
falschen weg
die notsituation in deutschland ist groß
genug
das merken wir an den pisa-ergebnissen
die schlechter werden das merken wir
daran dass es einen exorbitanten
lehrkräftemangel gibt da kann man da
muss man an einem strang ziehen
schon jetzt wird deutlich viele
bundesländer wollen an ihren eigenheiten
festhalten es bleibt ein weiter weg hin
zum ende des flickenteppichs im
deutschen schulwesen
so jetzt nach madrid wo gerade
zehntausende gegen den klimawandel auf
die straße gehen es ist eine
großdemonstration weil in madrid seit
vier tagen die weltklimakonferenz läuft
mittendrin ist auch die schwedische
klimaaktivisten greta tim berg die am
vormittag am bahnhof in madrid ankam
riesen großer andrang und nur mit hilfe
der polizei konnte sie den zug verlassen
volker angeles beobachtet demonstration
in madrid folge haben die menschen dort
denn den eindruck dass ihre forderungen
auch gehört werden von der
weltklimakonferenz
ganz offenbar nicht sonst würden hier
nicht 10.000 sondern an die
hunderttausend menschen auf die straße
gegangen seien
sie alle erwarten deutliche signale vom
klimagipfel
die gibt es bis jetzt nämlich nicht vor
allem die eu muss nachbessern
und zwar nicht die ziele 2050 sondern
die ziele 20.30 müssen angehoben werden
da muss einfach mehr klimaschutz
passieren
die entwicklungsländer sagen die
versprochenen 100 milliarden us-dollar
die habe nächsten jahr fließen sollen
reichen schon jetzt nicht um die schäden
des klimawandels die immer stärker
werden auszugleichen
und auch beim dritten thema den globalen
emissionshandel gibt es erhebliche
schwächen denn dann befürchtet dass
bilanztechnisch die klimaschutzmaßnahmen
doppelt angerechnet werden was natürlich
da nur der heil mit klimaschutz wäre
also die protestaktion hier völlig zu
recht in der nächsten woche muss noch
wesentlich mehr passieren
volker angres hat sich dank die
französische regierung will ihre
rentenreform durchziehen trotz der
proteste im ganzen land präsident
emanuel makro kündigte an am mittwoch
erste details seiner rentenpläne bekannt
zu geben
der generalstreik im öffentlichen dienst
hat mittlerweile den zweiten tag in
folge den verkehr besonders im großraum
paris praktisch lahmgelegt die meisten
züge und u bahnen stehen still schulen
bleiben geschlossen und der protest soll
am wochenende weitergehen von
kollektivem versagen spricht die
weltgesundheitsorganisation denn wieder
mehr menschen erkranken an masern einer
hoch ansteckenden krankheit die
schlimmstenfalls tödlich endet die whu
schätzt dass sich letztes jahr weltweit
rund 9,8 millionen menschen angesteckt
haben mehr als 140.000 seien daran
gestorben die meisten von ihnen waren
kleine kinder nicht mal fünf jahre alt
und dieses jahr werden es wohl noch mehr
besonders betroffen der kongo aber auch
die ukraine und ganz aktuell der kleine
inselstaat samoa im pazifik der muss
jetzt mit allen mitteln gegen die masern
kämpfen wie normen odenthal zeigt die
ansage ist laut und deutlich zu hause
bleiben es herrscht gesundheitsnotstand
aus
die straßen leer freie fahrt nur für
polizei und ärzteteams die sind
unterwegs um nachzuholen was versäumt
wurde impfung gegen masern mehr als 60
tote seit ende oktober die meisten
kleine kinder
die masern welle hat den pazifik staat
überrollt die angst geht um der kleine
mahlow bekam den ausschlag jetzt auch
hat fieber wirkt apathisch
ich mache mir solche sorgen ich wollte
ihn schon ins krankenhaus bringen aber
die busse fahren ja nicht und die
straßen sind gesperrt
die ärzte nehmen marlow mit er ist jetzt
einer von mehr als 4000 infizierten das
land hat gerade mal 200.000 einwohnern
impfen hätte all das verhindert aber
geimpft wird viel zu wenig auf samoa und
weltweit unwissen aberglaube angst das
sind wohl die häufigsten gründe mit dem
ergebnis die masern sind wieder auf dem
vormarsch
elsie durchlebt deshalb die schwärzesten
stunden ihre tochter ist tot nur ein
jahr war sie alt es ist so schwer sein
kind zu verlieren
ich werde meinen ul nie vergessen sie
war gerade erst dabei sprechen zu lernen
vor dem ausbruch war nur jeder dritte
auf samoa geimpft der es jetzt noch
nicht ist hat eine rote fahne vorm haus
die erste teams sind unterwegs um die
spritzen zu setzen aber zu oft ist es zu
spät
eine situation die aufrütteln müsste
jetzt mal den sport in der sendung und
das bist du christine haben so was wie
einen krimi heute erlebt hochgradig
emotional das letzte vorrundenspiel der
deutschen handballerinnen bei der wm in
japan gegen südkorea lagen sie erst klar
in führung dann fast aussichtslos zurück
und am ende gleichauf unentschieden und
nun lockt sogar das halbfinale
das deutsche team hoch motiviert und mit
starkem beginn vor allem dank schneller
gegenstöße mit präzisen pässen für
deutschland zeitweise mit sechs toren
vorsprung
doch dann kippt das spiel einfachste
aktionen misslingen südkorea liegt sechs
minuten vor schluss mit vier toren in
führung
wir haben heute ein traum statisch dann
super in der abwehr waren hannah ist ein
bisschen hektischer wurde die ruhe zu
bewahren
das gelingt erst in den letzten minuten
wieder dank eines überragenden endspurts
kann maren weigel zum 27 27 ausgleichen
sekunden vor schluss emily berg sogar
noch mit der siegchance deutschland
zieht nun mit 31 punkten als zweitbestes
team in die hauptrunde ein
der traum von der ersten medaille seit
2007 lebt weiter heißer kampf um die
tabellenspitze in der fußball bundesliga
schalke und leipzig mit der chance
mönchengladbach zu verdrängen wenn mir
wenn die bayern bei der borussia gewinn
es ist nur eine kleine delle im neuen
selbstverständnis der bayern das 1 2
gegen leverkusen offenbarte viele
möglichkeiten nur muss man sie liegen
gegen gladbach soll das anders werden
dafür so unser bestes zu bringen auf den
platz zu bringen auf den punkt zu
bringen
die mannschaft hat erfahrung genug sie
hat qualität genug um auch mit dieser
situation zurechtzukommen
eine niederlage und die bayern wären
plötzlich sieben punkte hinter der
spitze zurück gladbach dürfte dann mit
großem interesse den blick auf schalke
richten denn auch dort greift die
euphorie langsam um sich auch wenn man
in leverkusen antreten muss wir
respektieren unseren gegner wollen
nichtsdestotrotz nach anschauen und
gucken dass wir gegner unabhängig oder
auch unabhängig davon ob wir zu hause
oder auswärts spielen unser spiel auf
dem auf dem platz bringen ein sieg um
anschaut sicherlich anders dran denn
schalke wäre dann weiter ganz oben mit
dabei
also sportstudium morgen abend gucken
lohnt sich auf jeden fall immer du
frierst hier im studio du frierst auch
draußen christin das wetter es kaum der
rede wert morgen meist grau im norden
ziehen dann auch noch schauer durch und
als würde das nicht reichen hat gunther
tiersch für heute nacht noch eine
glatteis warnung
bleiben sie zu hause am besten mit dem
heute journal um 22 uhr claus kleber
spricht mit der neuen spd chefin saskia
esken morgen freut sich hier petra
gerster auf sie
ich danke fürs interesse und vom
gesamten heute 19 uhr team in hallen
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
genommen liebe zuschauer jetzt wird's
wieder mild nass und windig und die
wetteränderung ist ja im vollen gange
wir haben schon den regen über
deutschland hier liegt über der mitte
der zieht weiter überquerte uns und
morgen kommen dann von der nordsee
etliche schauer nach die vor allem über
norddeutschland ziehen im süden bleibt
es dabei etwas ruhiger aber eben auch
meist trocken heute nacht aber regnet es
auch im süden und südosten das bedeutet
glätte vorhanden in bayern
der boden ist noch gefroren da gefriert
dann dagegen sehr schnell und wir haben
dazu einen kräftigen zum teil
stürmischer südwest- bis westwind
frostig wird eben vor allen dingen noch
mal in bayern bis zu minus vier grad
vielleicht in der eifel hunsrück 0 grad
sonst bleibt es frostfrei und morgen ja
da wird es dann schon deutlich milder
meist sind es zwischen 5 und 10 grad wie
hier zum beispiel am oberrhein und es
wird ein grauer ein trüber tag mit regen
vor allen dingen norddeutschland anfangs
zwischen erzgebirge und der ostsee und
dann am nachmittag auch im nordwesten im
süden bleibt es meist trocken da gibt es
nur anfangs ein paar schauer und es ist
nicht mehr ganz so windig es weht ein
kräftiger westwind dazu die aussichten
stürmisch am sonntag neuer sturm neuer
regen montag wechselhaftes wetter und am
dienstag wird es ruhiger kälter und im
süden gibt schnee
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut